there's nothing like it it's totally
cool you're going a place you have no
idea what it's like you only go and
explore it and no other humans have seen
it so you're seeing things for the first
time in 2006 the New Horizons spacecraft
left earth bound for Pluto nine and a
half years later it is about to arrive
to know that there's something out there
waiting for you to discover is just
probably one of the most exciting things
I've been able to do excitement over
Pluto is nothing new even before its
discovery the idea that there could be a
ninth planet was intriguing astronomers
in 1930 clyde tombaugh at the Lowell
Observatory was searching the skies for
the elusive Planet X thought to be
responsible for disrupting Neptune's
orbit what he found was Pluto in the
years that followed Pluto firmly
embedded itself in the public
consciousness when Pluto lost its status
as a planet there was a public outcry
somehow reclassifying a lump of rock 7.5
billion kilometres away was something
everyone had an opinion on even though
we still knew very little about it for
decades
Pluto was no more than a dot of light in
a telescope until scientists decided it
was time for a closer look back in 1989
Alan Stern and I organized a conference
to get interest going on Pluto and a
bunch of keen people turned up and got
it started and we've been working on
getting a mission and getting the
mission there and we're nearly that now
New Horizons is about to take the first
ever close-up pictures of this strange
distant world it's like never having
gone in your backyard and when you go
out there what are you going to find you
can think of Pluto as the icy leftover
remnants of the debris from the
formation of the solar system those
billions of years ago kept in cold
storage just waiting for us
unlock the mysteries it's like
archeology in the outer solar system
Pluto is not alone 50 years after its
discovery astronomers found a moon
orbiting Pluto almost half Pluto's with
it was named Sharon more moons would
follow Nix Hydra Kerberos and Styx the
last only spotted three years ago but
it's not just moons keeping Pluto
company astronomers have found other
large bodies out there at the edges of
the solar system lots of them you get a
sense Wow this objects out there the
Kuiper belt Oh Pluto got moons got more
moons
it's got neighbors one called Eris is as
large as Pluto itself and it was Eris
that spelled the end of Pluto's planet
status rather than classify all these
new objects as planets scientists
downgraded Pluto to a dwarf planet along
with several other distant rocks dwarf
people are people are they not for
planets of planets
but whatever its size or status Pluto
still fascinates us I used to do cave
exploration when I was a student and you
go in and you see this passage and he
goes around the corner and you want to
know what's around the corner right it's
the same thing with planets that's the
nature of human curiosity and we're
going to find out